this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at the 2023
remake of System Shock this has got a
sort of double pump to double charge the
ammunition so it's like pumping a second
round into the chamber which obviously
would be impossible with a conventional
firearm make sure to subscribe and let
us know what other games or guns you'd
like to see Jonathan break down in the
comments section below right let's take
a look at the Sci-Fi Weaponry of System
Shock
all right so this is a pretty unusual
looking pistol I think it's fair to say
but it functions very simply very it's
very pistoly
it functions much like a contemporary
self-loading pistol but the the sort of
art design of it is very different and
seeing it on its own on the floor at the
beginning there without seeing the
environments or the characters or
anything I have to say I thought it
looked a bit ugly but in context it does
it does match the art style talking back
to the original system shot I guess
um I should stay up front I don't
remember any of the weapons from that
game I do remember the game right so the
most information I'm getting from this
is in in the reload animation where we
can see that this is a slide but the gun
is very blocky underneath like it has an
upper receiver inside the slide which is
a bit weird normally you see the exposed
barrel and there'd be just sort of
negative space and then the bottom of
the frame but this in this case the
frame is really tall and envelops the
barrel and the slide is wrapped over the
top of that that's quite unusual and the
magazine has it has sort of witness
holes so you can see the rounds but at
the top which isn't well I guess it
still works you could still see when you
were low on very low in ammunition if
you pop the magazine out the rounds
appear to be they do they are depicting
complete rounds in the magazine when the
cases come out they appear to just be
plain cylinders with a flat base so yeah
this is an unusual one I think
foreign
bit of a gear change here from a
conventional ish cartridge firearm to
something very well Star Trek is what
leaps to mind some of the sort of ribs
and the general curve shape of this says
I don't know next Generation movie era
track phaser to me with some additional
kind of stuff on the front I'm not sure
what that does so it almost looks like
yellow and black Hazard markings and
then there's a sort of a bridge tight
Armature thing around the muzzle don't
know what that's supposed to do what it
does in in aesthetic sense is break up
that otherwise quite organic curve and
then I was thinking the lights on the
top were going to be the phaser power
setting they're not that's an
overheating gauge so we have the
standard Trope of energy weapons blue
blue electricity in this case it
overheating the weapon as a sort of
substitute Prime Edition sometimes you
get both but usually it's one or the
other and then what I had to really hunt
for on the model which if this was a
real thing would be a negative point in
terms of ergonomics and human factors
and all of that is the actual selector
it has three positions on the side and a
dial and there's low medium and high so
like like microwave cooking or something
and you kind of are microwave cooking on
the high setting because they turn into
chunks
foreign
guns here and first first reaction is
this looks a bit Oblivion assault rifle
if you remember the Tom Cruise sci-fi
film Oblivion which I believe I remember
rightly was an ACR uh Remington ACR in a
in a very well designed casing and
actually look looked very different
still with a little bit of a Star Trek
phase of vibe I think just from just
from some of the styling I don't think
I'm going to be seeing energy bolts
coming out of this thing though I'm
going to be seeing gunfire we have got a
futuristic take on the picatinny rail
which really just looks like a picatinny
rail but as we've used before on this
series it's hard to improve on that
basic design I think I think that could
be with us for a long time and then
details like the we have a selector with
it with an LED to show you what you've
selected we can see a magazine catch we
can see a cocking handle
um let's see how it operates
foreign
two types of ammunition I think it's
magnesium that can set enemies on fire
or there's a round that's just called
penetrator which punches through armor a
bit better can you tell is there a
readout for the ammo anywhere or is it
just I think red is uh magnesium blue is
the penetrate around from from memory
and the penetrator around is that meteor
sound as well which is nice oh yeah
right so in action we have two different
types of ammunition here and the ammo
counter is not just counting the rounds
it's telling you or reminding you I
suppose which type of ammunition you
have loaded we have a muzzle flash
that's different between the two and
effects are those little it was a little
hard to try and figure out what was
going on at first the effects on the
target are different as well so the blue
we've got conventional or armor-piercing
type purely kinetic rounds that are
notionally chipping off chunks of hot
metal from the wall I think is what's
being represented there and that's just
some plain damage and then there's a an
orange colored readout and that's giving
us a different muzzle flash a different
report as well so you once you've played
the game for a while you should know
pretty quickly which one you're using
you've got an audible indicator you've
got two or three visual indicators
depending on what you're looking at
that's somewhat somewhat unique I think
how sort of effective these different
rounds are on different enemies is not
incredibly evident from from footage but
I assume that there is a a noticeable
effect to make it worth having those
different rounds in the game trying to
figure that out made me realize that
when the magazine is being removed from
the rifle the county the counter goes
down to zero which means the rounds are
feeding straight from the magazine like
an open bolt firearm assuming the weapon
is functioning correctly when you detach
the magazine there should be no rounds
left in the gun whereas a closed bolt
weapon there will always be around left
in the chamber when you remove the
magazine if they were replicating that
effect as it were that system then you
would always have the wrong round on
fire first for the next shot they're
either thinking open bolt I don't think
so because it doesn't look like it
functions that way or they are just the
sake of gameplay let's just have when we
take the ammunition out all the
ammunition comes out
thank you
detox another energy weapon with a
similar sort of system three settings
again although for some reason they're
not lighting up different colors which I
think would probably be helpful with
this with these three Blue Darts being
in just slightly different positions I
don't think that's a great control
system for what's essentially your
selector switch but anyway my minor
point the overall design of this I
really like the the curves and the
panels the animated portions with the
the expanding muzzle purpose which isn't
entirely clear but I think it's to do
with heat dissipation and certainly the
three well presumably six heat sinks
that pop out of the side it's all very
sort of dynamic and impressive and you
know that something big is coming when
you do the big charge shot that we've
seen and then we've got the the heat bar
above the um on the rear setting which
sort of showcases the the pixel art or
3D Pixel Art almost sort of Quake to
reminiscent it's obviously better
graphics than that but you can see that
it it's semi-track it's translated
recent this window on the back of the
weapon that contains your readout but
it's also pixely so that's it's quite
it's clearly a conscious design choice
and and I find it quite interesting but
this this whole weapon so far for me is
the is the most successful design the
way it combines the way it delivers the
damage with how it's animated with how
it's held with its General lines as a as
a science fiction weapon
this is the mag pulse rifle okay it's uh
electromagnetic charges
but if you pump twice the the game in in
the game it says it fuses two cartridges
or two charges together to fire one big
one it's basically you know like a slow
throwing electromagnetic shotgun yeah
interesting right next up we have the
mag pulse and I thought this was
probably going to be a machine pistol or
something but uh I'm not sure why in
retrospect um just just the sort of form
factor of it as it were but it's
actually it functions as a very compact
sawn off pump shotgun but it's using
some sort of energy ammunition
magnetically accelerated or something in
fact when it's fired it makes it a very
sort of electromagnetic sounding noise
to me anyway but how it functions is
kind of bizarre so that we have the pump
grip that encloses the weapon but then
under that there's a slide as well but
that only moves when you reload it's a
bit like when there's a mistaken reload
animation where the slide only locks to
the rear when you hit the magazine catch
I'm not sure that's the intention that's
obviously not the intention but I don't
know that that applies here because of
the weird electric ammunition having
said that the uh the magazine is like a
normal magazine in the pistol grip for a
normal pistol which goes against the
idea of it being a shotgun would expect
a tube magazine if this was a shotgun
but of course this is a science fiction
weapon so they can do what they want and
they have and the the really interesting
aspect is the double double pump so
instead of being able to fire say have
two barrels and you can choose to fire
one or both and then you just reload the
one if you don't fire both this has got
a sort of double pump to double charge
the ammunition so it's like pumping a
second round into the chamber which
obviously would be impossible with a
conventional firearm here it's sort of
using electrical energy to accelerate
something I'm not sure what some sort of
plasma hard to say certainly an
interesting weapon that's changing
things up a bit while still having a
familiar mechanic for for as you know
for an FPS
okay another very chunky pistol with the
same stylings as the uh the smaller
pistol and reminiscent of the magpulse
as well is this kind of Desert Eagle in
space it's a bigger more powerful pistol
as the description implies what it
doesn't seem to have as much in the way
of recoil don't know if it's supposed to
have inherent recoil dampening or
something physics is hard to get around
so
um I don't know how they've done that if
they have but fundamentally this
operates just like an ordinary pistol
the slide kind of motored itself to the
rear at the point of reloading quite
slowly which is weird I'm not really
sure what's going on there so we fire a
fire our last shot and then instead of
the energy of that shot essentially
whether it's blowback or or lock breach
instead of that propelling the slide to
the rear it's like it doesn't yeah I
don't know it's like so recall damped
that it doesn't have any recoil that
affects the slide at all and then it
Motors its side open for you to reload I
don't understand that at all in fact
something I failed to point out on the
low power pistol so let's point it out
on the Magnum is this are the sights
which look like iron sights that someone
forgot to file the groove in
the rear of this is like mangle English
language there if you're not following
me here it's like there's a there's a
block at the front that would suffice
perhaps for a front sight but then
there's another solid block at the rear
but those are going to do very little
you can line up two solid metal blocks
and they're better than nothing maybe
but probably given that the rear sight
would obscure the front side entirely
you'd be better off with just a front
side or no sights at all and you know
it's coming where are the Red Dot sights
they're ought to be red if this is the
future of our universe or really any
Universe with this level of
technological sophistication there
should be Red Dot sights or something
even better on absolutely everything by
default there'd be no reason for iron
sights least of all Iron Sights that
don't even work
thank you
a grenade launcher I like this one the
sort of sore chainsaw grip that's that's
the phrase I'm looking for there's um a
weird pump action shotgun chainsaw type
grip that you can get to attach to a
shotgun so you pump it overhand some
some of you will have seen that I'm sure
this reminds me of that but it's um it's
something a bit different because we've
seen seen lots of different grenade
launchers they're usually just open with
a sort of unseen latch it's not usually
clear how that how they're opening up if
they are if that's how they load and
they're not just magazine fed single
shot grenade launches and rocket
launchers for that matter so this has a
nice nice big mechanism that makes some
noise and you can understand how it
works it opens a breach you're shoving
around you close it you fire it there's
no kind of fudging of how this thing is
working with Servo Motors or magnetic
levitating parts or anything like that
but it doesn't look like anything that
we have now so it's good
all right
right this says it's a rail gun and
probably could have guessed that it was
meant to be one even if it didn't didn't
say railgun in the head-up display so I
guess this is supplying both projectiles
that are being accelerated by the rails
so they look more like coils looking
through those opening flat things and
electricity I think there's a lot of
electric sparking going on and those so
we insert that the whole thing in
including what looked like the coils and
then those flaps with the blue lights on
close over the top not entirely clear
what's supposed to be going on but hey
how do I know how a handheld rail gun is
going to function right so it looks like
you can you can somehow boost this thing
using the energy of your suit so we see
these these flaps close up so one finger
at a time quite slowly but they the
whole thing process was sped up by the
suit there so it's not entirely logical
as to why that would I guess your the
magazine supplying the the bullets or
onto the better term and it's sort of
onboard electricity T but you're able to
inject some in from your suit I guess it
sort of makes sense that you just
locking the magazine in gives you your
projectiles charging the gun from the
capacitor or whatever on the magazine
that I guess is the bit that's being
sped up so there's as much sense as I
can make of it if you see
actual railguns being fired it is just
nothing it's a it's a very very fast
projectile that you can't see with a
naked eye and then the effect on the
target you wouldn't see anything to
speak of at the other end and you
wouldn't get a trail
um I guess in certain atmosphere
atmospheric conditions you might get a
trail there's no projectile Trail here
you definitely get the sense it has it
has recoil and it has a sort of high
energy sounding effect as those coils
are energized so it's as good a rail gun
as any really
this being the game's SMG it apparently
fires nine millimeter but can shoot
Teflon coated rounds lots of different
ammo types in this game so you mentioned
Teflon coated rounds that's a real thing
I can't even remember why it was done
originally but there were there was a
certain brand of Teflon coated
ammunition in the markets in the US back
in the 80s I think it was and it became
hugely controversial because the the
concern was that the Teflon would let it
penetrate Kevlar and it would be a cop
killer round which I believe was not
true suffice to say the technology
exists whatever whatever purpose it may
it may have in real life uh not much I
would suggest because I'm not aware of
Teflon being used to coat bullets
anymore so clearly there's a reason for
doing it in the future I'm not sure what
that is on the face of it this is a
pretty conventional submachine gun it's
it's visibly a modern machine the
machine submachine gun it has a stock
made sci-fi so again a bit like the
pistols it doesn't really do anything
that say a um P or or it's namesake a
scorpion EVO 3 wouldn't do if you just
put that in the game I'm not saying they
should have by any means because I don't
know when this is set but uh most of
those would probably be in bits by
that's fine so we expect to see
something new and different what I'm
getting at is that these bullet firing
weapons in the game aren't really
bringing much to the table that their
modern day counterparts don't do
this is the in-game shotgun there's two
ammunition types flechette and dragon's
breath and it's actually called Dragon's
breath in the game as well so it's not
just some nod someone failed to
trademark dragon's breath so you've got
either tiny darts
on lots of fire all right it's another
pump action shotgun in space because we
don't seem to be able to get away from
the pump action shotgun I think they've
done a good job of differentiating it
with the enveloping pump grip as it were
there's no reason to to have it wrapped
around the front of the weapon like that
but it does look distinctive and it
looks does look cool two different ammo
effects here one is equivalent to
Buckshot I hope I'm informed that it's
uh that it's bruschettes there's no way
you could know that and to be fair if
you're shooting it out the end of a gun
you're not necessarily going to know
that either difference in reality is
quite significant though the shetts are
well pretty questionable a pretty
questionable load for for a shotgun they
are meant to be more penetrative but
they are very small diameter they're
like little needles so they're going to
do a lot less damage than a 32 Caliber
Buckshot pellet times nine or whatever
the ammunition you're shooting so the
effects we're seeing here are maybe more
consistent with Buckshot and the
fleshette thing is kind of a well it's a
futuristic shotgun so it's firing
projects what's different is or somewhat
different is the incendiary effect here
which is being described as dragon's
breath which is fair enough but it
doesn't look like dragon's breath the
the sort of the Magnesium particle
effect that you get from from Dragon's
Breath is quite distinctive this looks
more like some other incendiary of
effect with with burning gas or
something almost so it has its own it
has its own effect and I think I can
tell even without playing it that the
flame effect is way more effective on
the organic enemies and it doesn't do a
great deal to the robotic ones so that
would be the reason for you've got your
pseudo AP plus shirt rounds for the
robot and you switch to your dragon's
breath for the
salt squishy people
all right guys those were the guns of
System Shock uh the new one that is hope
you enjoyed it please do join us here at
the Royal armories if you can in person
if not we have all sorts of electronic
goings on including our own YouTube
channel and various social media outlets
and keep an eye out for any events that
might be happening later in the year in
any case we'll see you again next time